the malevolent Ciroc brought the city of
baldur's gate to the edge of destruction
you like him
our child
balls who saw his own death and sired
mortal children in an effort to bring
about his return Salva intended to
become the new lord of murder you put an
end to Sara Vox plans and slew your
half-brother with his passing
you became known as the hero of baldur's
gate
[Applause]
No
thread casts a shadow over the city a
massive army on a holy crusade has
thrown the sword coast into turmoil
little is known the Crusades leader the
charismatic warrior Kayla argent those
who follow her revere her as the shining
lady but her background and goals are
surrounded in mystery some say she
mystified a hero sent by the gods to
crush evil no matter the cost
others whisper that she is another small
intent on following the same path as
Sarawak one thing above all else is
clear if the sword coast is to find any
measure of peace tailor argent must be
stopped
[Music]
[Music]
you came good I was curious I had to
learn who would be so arrogant so
foolish as to summon me in such a
fashion who are you who thinks himself
my equal my better even judging by your
messages tone you know if you little not
you think I do I've done enough you are
too perhaps you are right
perhaps not you do not speak for the
Accord and I do not bow to the demands
of some broken themes licks
the first battle is lost my lady and our
fall says walk to the castle college
position there here hold I'm heartened
to see you're still with us that makes
no difference now one of those tasks I
asked you to perform
[Music]
[Music]
for Dagg referred your list
[Music]
[Music]
you